elle avec à pascal crêpés
épidémiologistes et enseignant chercheur
à l'école des hautes études en santé
publique
bonjour parce qu'elle crée merci d'être
avec nous ce matin sur rtl france alors
on a parlé de cette date du 3 mai en
tout cas c'est le gouvernement qui en a
parlé pour un début de de déconfinement
alors il faut mesurer bien entendu ce
elle ce mot puisque ce sont seulement
les contraintes de déplacement en
journée qui seraient levés pour
commencer est ce que ce déconfinement le
3 mai vous paraît être le bon timing
alors le bon timing
c'était difficile a dit enfin tout
dépend en fait des mesures qui sont
prises et puis de quel point elles
seront ensuite respecté et et parler à
la population et puis éventuellement
étendu ce qui est certain c'est que nous
sommes actuellement sur une pente très
douce ce qui montre que le contrôle pas
qu'il ya un contrôle de l'épidémie mais
moins fort que ce que nous avons pu
connaître lors des deux précédents
confinement est donc la situation reste
fragile et il va falloir réussir à
rester sur cette pente malgré c'est ce
relâchement vis-à-vis de nos activités
sociales qui peuvent être le lieu de
contamination est ce que justement vous
nous dire que le timing n'est peut-être
pas forcément tout de suite le bon
équivalent en tout cas continuer à
falloir faire attention
est-ce que vous pensez que c'était aussi
le moment peut être quelque part
d'assouplir ses règles sanitaires
je pense qu'il faut bien comprendre que
nous sommes maintenant à plus d'un an de
crise épidémique n'est qu'une grande
fatigue et s'est installé dans la
population et cette fatigue en fait elle
et elle donne aussi à
ben aux gens le wall tout cas elle
pousse un peu la population à faire de
temps en temps des écarts et donc et ça
on peut leur reprocher à personne et
donc si si il y à un mois il ya une des
solutions pour donner un peu d'air à la
population mais de façon relativement
sécurisé je pense par exemple à la
réouverture des terrasses des bars et
des restaurants qui qui peuvent
permettre de faire en sorte que les gens
retrouvent une forme d'activités
sociales d'interactions sociales mais
dans un contexte plutôt sécurisées
plutôt contrôlé d'un point de vue
sanitaire parce qu'on sait que les
contaminations sont quand même beaucoup
moins nombreuses en extérieur eh bien ça
peut permettre que la population en
général respecte encore un peu mieux les
consignes qui consiste à dire de ne pas
se retrouver en intérieur parce que
c'est vraiment en intérieur que l'on se
contaminent donc donc ça peut enfin ce
relâchement comme comme vous dites peut
aussi permettre de retrouver une
meilleure efficacité vis-à-vis de ce
contrôle de l'épidémie
vous parliez tout à l'air d'une pente
traînante 1 par rapport aux deux autres
confinement que l'on a déjà connu jean
castex en parlait de cette troisième
vague du pic de cette troisième vague et
il disait que que ce pic était justement
à derrière nous est ce que c'est aussi
votre avis sur le terrain alors moi je
ne suis pas sur le terrain je suis pas
médecin je suis fier logist donc on a
effectivement je regarde les données et
effectivement on voit s'infléchir les
différences un négateur on voit ces
fléchir les les courbes malheureusement
très lentement il n'y a pas
d'infléchissement brutale l'attention
spéciale hier reste très forte
on a même l'impression d'une certaine
stabilité au niveau des entrées en
réanimation qu'on espère que les choses
s'améliorent et parmi les choses qui
nous permettent d'espérer que les choses
que tout cela s'améliore lie à l'avancé
de la vaccination et puis l'arrivée
aussi du beau temps on sait qu'il ya un
phénomène aussi saisonniers
vis-à-vis des contaminations de plus en
plus être en extérieur à errer tout ça
va contribuer à limiter le risque de
contamination et donc devrait nous
permettre de nous aider à contrôler un
peu mieux cette épidémie on parlait
également tout à l'heure de la
réouverture des classes pour pour les
écoles maternelles et les écoles
primaires justement des élèves qui vont
passer des tests salivaires et puis un
protocole très strict sera mise en place
en cas de contamination d'un élève est
ce que là aussi les règles vous semble
adaptée pour une réouverture des classes
en toute sécurité
lorsqu'il faut savoir c'est qu'il n'y a
pas de consensus scientifique très fort
vis-à-vis du rôle des écoles dans
l'épidémie certains pensent qu'il ya
qu'elles ont un rôle majeur
d'autres pensent que le rôle pour les
pieds de de sart skov de est plutôt
relativement mineures les études durent
défaite en france ont tendance plutôt à
montrer que les enfants sont à la fois
moins contaminant et moins contaminée se
sont tous les enfants jusqu'au juste aux
primaires a choisi les choses sont un
peu différentes pour les collégiens et
les lycéens et donc avec en plus un
protocole d'accès state et puis du
dépistage très régulier avec notamment
ce délestage
ces tests salivaires on devrait pouvoir
limiter les contaminations et faire en
sorte que l'épidémie ne reprennent pas
que l'on ne retrouve pas une hausse de
la sinne hausse de l'incidence suite à
la couverture les écoles mais encore une
fois il va falloir bien surveiller tous
les indicateurs pour s'assurer que les
choses se comporte comme on l'espère
merci beaucoup parce qu'elle crée paix
d'avoir été avec nous ce matin d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes épidémiologistes et enseignant
chercheur à l'école des hautes études en
santé publique merci beaucoup